You've had a terrible week, you're stressed
out, sad, angry at the world.
If you're like a lot of people, you might
turn to food.
Hey folks, Laci Green here for Dnews.
Emotional eating, or stressed eating, is basically
when you to feed a feeling instead of eating
to feed your tummy.
Everyone will do it at some point or another
but it's something that definitely affects
some people in more serious ways than others.
Common wisdom says that when we're stressed
out, we turn to comfort foods, fatty foods,
delicious-sweet-salty and not-so-good-for-your-body
foods.
This week, a new study done at UCLA, is trying
to discount that idea.
The researchers took 59 MBA students and surveyed
them about their eating habits.
Then, during midterm exams, they offered them
a broad assortment a fine snacks to choose
from.
Some are on the healthy side like fruit, yogurt
and wheat crackers.
Others were on the not so healthy side like
candy bars, chips and cookies.
They found that the snacks students picked
were the snack closest to what they usually
eat.
Health-conscious students picked healthy snacks
and those with poor diets picked unhealthy
snacks.
The lead psychologist on this study, David
Neal, claims that when we're stressed out,
habits determine our food choices, not craving.
But I'm not so sure about that.
Something is a little fishy to me here, guys.
This claim contradicts all the other research
on the topic and it's also worth mentioning
that the study was presented at a food technologist
conference and isn't a peer-reviewed.
So Harvard Medical School claims that when
we're stressed out, we do gravitate toward
unhealthy foods.
Carbs and fat have the effect of activating
the reward centers in the brain and inhibiting
stress feedback.
It's a soft little, "SShh.
Here just feel good for a second."
And it works.
The Journal of Physiology and Behavior found
that many people eat more and tend to more
caloricly dense foods when they're stressed
out.
Possibly because of a pesky little hormone
called Ghrelin and that's released when you're
stressed.
This is one of the ways that stress can lead
to weight gain.
Why it's so hard to lose weight when you're
stressed.
And it also hints at a relationship between
obesity and stress levels.
Some scientists have said that America's obesity
epidemic is actually a stress epidemic.
So no, stress doesn't always lead to emotional
eating even in people who are emotional eaters.
Some people have the opposite reaction and
certainly in the short term, stress can kill
an appetite.
There is no stranger feeling and looking at
a delicious plate a food and being unable
to stomach it because you're so worried or
nervous about something.
This happens because stress at the fight-or-flight
nature can cause your hypothalamus produce
Corticotropin-releasing hormone, or CRH, which
suppresses appetite.
It's more in the long term constant stress
that leads to overeating and the cravings.
So do eating habits play any role in our stressed
out food choices?
I'm sure they do, but that doesn't mean that
stress cravings aren't a thing.
Let me know what you guys think down below
or on Twitter at @dnews and I'll see you next
time.